The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's start.
So last time, having
dealt with the ideal gas
as much as possible, we started
with interacting systems.
Let's say interacting gas.
And the first topic
that we did was
what I called an approach
towards interaction
through the Cumulant expansion.
The idea is that we certainly
solved the problem where
we had particles in a box and
it was just a trivial system.
Basically, the particles were
independent of each other
in the canonical ensemble.
And things become interesting
if you put interactions
among all of the particles.
Very soon, we will
have a specific form
of this interaction.
But for the beginning,
let's maintain
it as general as possible.
And the idea was
that we are trying
to calculate the partition
function for a system that
has a given temperature.
The box has some volume V and
there are N particles in it.
And to do so, we have
to integrate over
the entirety of the phase
space of N particles.
So we have to integrate over all
of the momenta and coordinates
of e to the minus beta h.
But we said that we are
going to first of all,
note that for
identical particles,
we can't tell apart
the phase space
if you were to make these in
[? factorial ?] permutations.
And we also made
it dimensionless
by dividing by h to the 3n.
And then we have e
to the minus beta
h, which has a part that is
e to the minus sum over i pi
squared over 2m, that
depends on the momenta.
And a part that depends
on the interaction U.
The integrals over the
momenta, we can easily perform.
They give us the
result of Gaussians
that we can express as
lambda to the power of 3n
where we introduced this lambda
to be h over root 2 pi m k t.
And actually, sort
of keeping in mind
the result that we had for
the case of the ideal gas,
let's rewrite this as V over
lambda cubed to the power of N.
So I essentially divided
and multiplied by V to the N
so that this part
becomes the partition
function than I would
have had if U was absent.
And so then the remainder is the
integral over all of the q's,
but I divided by
V. So basically,
with each integration,
I'm uniformly
sampling all of the points
inside the box with probability
density 1/V e to
the minus beta U.
And we said that
this quantity we
can regard as sampling
e to the minus beta U
through 0 to all
other probability
distribution in which the
particles ideal-like are
uniformly distributed.
And we call this e
to the minus beta U.
And the index 0
again to indicate
that we are dealing
with a uniform 0
to order distribution
with respect
to which this average is taken.
And then, this quantity
we can write as Z0.
And this exponential
we can formally
express as a sum
over all, let's say,
l running from 0 to
infinity minus beta
to the l divided by l factorial.
Then, expanding this, a quantity
that depends on the coordinates
is U. So I could have U raised
to the l power, this kind
of average taken
with respect to that.
And immediately, my
writing something like this
suggests that what
I'm after eventually
is some kind of a
perturbation theory.
Because I know how to solve
the problem where U is absent.
That's the ideal gas problem.
Maybe we can start to move
away from the ideal gas
and calculate things
perturbatively
in some quantity.
And exactly what
that quantity is
will become apparent shortly.
At this time, it looks like
it's an expansion in beta U
having to be a small quantity.
Now, of course, for calculating
thermodynamic functions
and behaviors, we don't
really rely usually on Z,
but log Z, which can be
related to the free energy,
for example.
So taking the log
of that expression,
I have a term that is log of Z0.
And a term that is
the log of that sum.
But we recognize that
that sum, in some sense,
is a generator of moments
of this quantity U.
And we have
experienced that when
we take the logarithm of a
generator of moments, what
we will get is a
generator of Cumulants,
now starting with l
equals to 1 minus beta
to the power of l
divided by l factorial U
to the l0 with a subscript c.
Of course, this subscript c sort
of captures all of the various
subtractions that you
have to make in order
to go from a moment
to a Cumulant.
But that's quite
general and something
that we know essentially is
relating log of the expansion
to the expansion itself.
But that's well-known.
So presumably, I can
perturbatively calculate these.
And I will have,
therefore, progressively
better approximations
to log Z in the presence
of this interaction.
Now at this point,
we have to start
thinking about a particular
expression for U.
So let's imagine that our U is a
sum over pairwise interactions.
So if I think about
the particles,
there are molecules that
are in the gas in this room.
Basically, the most important
thing is when the two of them
approach each other and I have
to put a pairwise interaction
between them of this form.
In principle, I could add
three-point and higher-order
interactions.
But for all intents
and purposes,
this should be enough.
And then again, what I
have here to evaluate,
the first term
would be minus beta,
the average of the first
power, and the next one
will be beta squared over 2.
For the first Cumulant,
it is the same thing
as the first moment.
The second Cumulant is the
thing that is the variance.
So this would have been
U squared 0 minus average
of U squared, and then
there will be higher orders.
So let's calculate these
first two moments explicitly
for this potential.
So the first term U in this 0
to order average, what is it?
Well, that's my U. So I
have to do a sum over i
and j of V of qi minus qj.
What does the averaging mean?
It means I have to integrate
this over all qi divided
by V. Let's call this qk divided
V and this is [INAUDIBLE].
OK, so let's say we look at the
first term in this series which
involves V of q1 minus q2.
Let's say we pick
that pair, q1 and q2.
And explicitly, what I have
here is integrals over q1, q2,
qn, each one of them
coming with a factor of V.
Now, of course, it doesn't
matter which pair I pick.
Everything is symmetric.
The weight that I start
with uniformly is symmetric.
So clearly, my
choice of this pair
was arbitrary and
the answer when
I do the sum is the answer for
1 times the number of pairs,
which is N N minus 1 over 2.
Now, over here I have
integrals over q3 or qn,
et cetera, that don't
appear in the function
that I'm integrating.
So all of those integrals
will give me factors of 1.
And really, the only thing
that I am going to be left with
is these two integrals
over q1 and q2.
But even then, the function
that I'm integrating
is only a function of
the relative coordinate
that I can call q.
And then I can, if I want,
integrate over q1 and q.
The integral over q1
would also give me
1 when I divide by the volume.
So the answer is going
to be N N minus 1 over 2,
which is the number of pairs.
The integral over the
relative coordinate times
the potential-- there
is a factor of 1 over V
that I can put out here.
So you tell me what the
first pair potential is
and I tell you that this is the
first correction that you will
get once you multiply
by minus beta
to log Z from which you
can calculate the partition
functions.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How did you turn the
product of two differentials
d q1 times d q2 into
just one differential?
PROFESSOR: OK, I have
the integral dq q1 dq q2,
some function of q1 minus q2.
I change variables keeping
q1 as one of my variables
and q [INAUDIBLE] replace
q2 with q minus q2.
So then I have the
integration over q1.
I have the integration over q2.
Not q2, but q f of q.
And then everything's fine.
All right, so that's
the first term.
Let's calculate the next term.
Next term becomes
somewhat interesting.
I have to calculate this
quantity as a Cumulant.
It's the variance.
V itself is a sum over pairs.
So to get V squared
to U squared,
I have to essentially
square this expression.
So rather than having
sum over one pair ij,
I have the sum over
two pairs ij and kl.
And then what I
need to calculate
is an average that if
I were to square this,
I will get v of qi minus
qj, v of qk minus ql 0.
This will be the
average of U squared.
But when I calculate
the variance,
I have to subtract from it
the average of U squared.
So I have to subtract V of
qi minus qj V of qk minus ql.
Fine.
So this is just rewriting
of that expression
in terms of the sum.
Now, each one of these is
N N minus 1 over two terms.
And so this, when I sum
over all possibility,
is the square of N N minus 1
over two possible terms that
will occur here in the
series that I've written.
Now, let's group those terms
that can occur in this as
follows.
One class of terms
will be when the pair
ij that I pick for the first sum
is distinct from the pair kl.
So huge number of terms
as I go through the pairs
will have this possibility.
OK, then what happens?
Then when I calculate the
average of qi minus qj qk minus
ql, which is this part, what
I need to do is to do all
of these integral of
this form over all q's.
And then I have this V of qi
minus qj V of qk minus ql.
Now, my statement is that
I have, let's say here,
q1 and q2 and somewhere
else q7 and q8.
Or, q7 and q974.
It doesn't matter.
The point is that
this integral that
involves this pair
of variables has
nothing to do with
the integral that
involves the other
pair of variables.
So this answer is the same
thing as the average of qi
minus qj average of qk minus ql.
Essentially, in the 0 order
probability that we are using,
the particles are
completely independently
exploring this space and these
averages will independently
rely on one pair
and independently
rely on another pair.
And once this kind of
factorization occurs,
it's clear that this
subtraction that I
need to do for the variance
will get rid of this term.
So these pairs do
not contribute.
No contribution.
If you like, this is this thing.
All right, so let's do the
next possible term, ij and ik,
with k not equal to this k.
So basically, I make the pairs
have one point in common.
So previously, I had a
pair here, a pair here.
Now I joined one
of their points.
So what do I get here?
I will get for this average
qi minus qj qi minus ql.
You can see that essentially,
the three integrals that I need
to worry about are
the integrals that
involve these three indices.
All the others will give me 0.
So this is going to be the
integral qi qj ql divided by V.
I have V of qi minus
qj V of qi minus ql.
AUDIENCE: You
switched [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
I think that's fine.
All right.
Now, I can do the same
thing that I did over here.
I have three variables.
I will pick qi to stay
as one of my variables.
I replace qj with this
difference, q j i.
I replace ql with
its distance to i.
And again, I can
independently integrate
over these three variables.
So this again,
becomes the same thing
as V of qi minus qj average
V of qi minus ql average.
And again, there
is no contribution.
Now, the first class it was
obvious because this pair
and this pair were
completely distinct.
This class is a
little bit more subtle
because I joined one
of the points together,
and then I used this and
this as well as this point
as independent variables.
And I saw that the sum
breaks into pieces.
And you won't be
surprised if no matter
how complicated I make various
more interactions over here,
I can measure all of the
coordinates with respect
to the single point and
same thing would happen.
This class of diagrams are
called 1-particle reducible.
And the first part had to
do with distinct graphs.
You didn't have to
worry about them.
But if I were to sort of
convert this expression--
and we will do so
shortly-- into graphs,
it corresponds to
graphs where there
is a point from which
everything else is hanging.
And measuring
coordinates with respect
to that point will allow the
average to break into pieces,
and then to be removed
through this subtraction.
So this is simple example of
something that is more general.
So at the level of this
second-order theorem,
the only type of thing
that will survive
is if the pairs are
identical, ij and other term
is also the same pair ij.
What do I get then?
I get V of qi minus
qj squared minus V
of qi minus qj 0 order squared.
So it's the variance of a
single one of these bond
contributions.
If I write that in
terms of integrals,
this becomes the
integral d cubed q1,
d cubed q2-- well, qi qj.
I will have factors
of V. Then, I
would have V squared qi
minus qj for the first term
and then the square of something
like this for the second term.
So putting everything
together up to this order,
what do I get?
I will get log Z,
which is log of Z0.
Let me remind you,
log of Z0 was N log
of V over lambda cubed N.
That's on form such as this.
And then I have
these corrections.
Note that both of the
terms that have survived
correspond to
looking at one pair.
So the corrections will be
of the order of N N minus 1
over 2.
Because in both cases, I
really look at one pair.
The first contribution was minus
beta integral d cubed q v of q.
There was a factor of
1 over V. Actually,
I can take-- well, let's
put the factor of 1 over V
here for the time being.
The next term will be
beta squared over 2
because I am looking at
the second-order term.
And what do I have?
I have the difference
of integral d cubed q
over V V squared.
And the square of the integral
of d cubed q over V V.
And presumably, there
will be higher-order terms
as we will discuss.
Now, I'm interested in the
limit of thermodynamics
where N and V are large.
And in that limit,
what do I get?
I will get log Z is log of Z0.
And then I can see that these
terms I can write as beta.
N N minus 1 I will
replace will N squared.
The factors-- here I
have a 1 over V. Here,
I have 1 over V squared.
So this factor is
smaller by an amount that
is order of V in
the large V-limit.
I will bring the
factor of V outside,
so I have something like this.
And then, what do I have here?
Actually, let's keep
this in this form,
minus beta integral
d cubed q V plus beta
squared over 2 integral d
cubed q V squared [INAUDIBLE].
So the kinds of things
that we are interested
and we can measure are
the energy of the system,
but let's say we
focus on pressure.
And if you look through various
things that we derived before,
beta times the
pressure you can get
from taking a derivative
of log Z with respect to V.
We can express the log Z in
terms of the free energy,
and then the derivative of free
energy with respect to volume
will give you the pressure of
the various factors of beta
[? and signs, ?] we
will come up with this.
So from the first term, N long
V, we get our ideal gas result.
Beta p is the same
thing as density.
And we see that we get a
correction from here when
I divide by-- when I take
a derivative with respect
to V of 1 over V, I will
get minus 1 over V squared.
So the next term would be
the square of the density.
And then, there is
a series that we
will encounter which depends
on the interaction potential.
Now, it turns out that
so far I have calculated
terms that relied on
only two points, ij.
And hence, they
become at the end
proportional to density squared.
If I go further
in my expansion, I
will encounter things that I
will need triangular points.
For example, i j k
forming a triangle.
And then, that would
give me something
that would be of the order
of the density cubed.
So somehow, I can also see
that ultimately this series
in perturbation theory,
as we shall see,
also more precisely can be
organized in powers of density.
Why is that important?
Because typically,
as we discussed right
at the beginning, when you
look at the pressure of a gas
when it is dilute and
over V is very small,
it is always ideal gas-like.
As you make it more
dense, you start
to get corrections that you can
express in powers of density.
And the coefficients of that
are called Virial coefficients.
So in some sense,
we have already
started in calculating the
second Virial coefficient,
and there are higher-order
Virial coefficients,
which together give you the
equation of states relating
pressure to density
by a power series.
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: The
Virial coefficients,
if they have integral
over the whole volume,
then they will be
functions of volume, right?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
But imagine that I'm thinking
about the gas in this room
and the interaction of
two oxygen molecules.
So what I am saying is you
pick an oxygen molecule.
There is interaction and
I have to integrate over
where the other
oxygen molecule is.
And by the time it
is tiny, tiny bit
[? away, ?] the
interaction is 0.
It doesn't really matter.
AUDIENCE: If the characteristic
volume of interaction
is much smaller than volume--
PROFESSOR: Of the space.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE], then
the integrals just converge
to [? constant. ?]
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So if you want to be
even more precise,
you will get corrections
when your particles are
close to the wall and
uniformity, et cetera,
is violated.
So there will, actually,
be corrections to, say, log
Z that are not only proportional
ultimately to number volume,
but the area of the enclosure
and other [? subleading ?]
factors.
But in the thermodynamic
limit, we ignore all of that.
So a lot of that is resolved
by this statement here.
Again, you won't be surprised
that if I were to go ahead,
then there will be a
term in this series that
would be beta cubed over 3
factorial integral over q
of vq, et cetera.
And that's actually very good
because as I have written
for you currently, this
expression is totally useless.
Why is it useless?
Because let's think back
about these two oxygen
molecules in the
gas in this room
and what the potential of
interaction between them
would look like.
Presumably, it is a function
of the relative separation.
We can call it r or
q, it doesn't matter.
And if you bring them
closer than the typical size
of these molecules, their
potential will go to infinity.
So basically, they don't want
to come close to each other.
If you go very far
away, typically you
have the van der
Waals attraction
between the particles.
So out here, it is attractive.
The potential is
negative and falls off,
typically, as 1 over
r to the 6 related
to the polarizabilities
of the particles.
And these, when you come
very short distances,
the electronic
clouds will overlap
and the potential
goes to infinity.
And if you want to sort of think
about numbers, typical scales
that we have here--
let's say here,
are presumably of the
order of angstroms.
And the typical depths
of these potentials
in units that make sense
to statistical physics
are of the order of
100 degrees Kelvin.
So it's why typical
gases liquidy
at range of temperatures
that is of the order of 100
degrees Kelvin.
Now, if I want to take this
potential and calculate this,
I have trouble.
Because the integral over
here will give me infinity.
So this expression
is, in general, fine.
But whenever you have
perturbation theory,
you start to evaluate
things and you
have to see whether
the correction indeed
is sufficiently small.
And it seems we can't make
it sufficiently small.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: If you're modeling
interatomic or intermolecular
potential as a
Lennard-Jones potential,
isn't the [INAUDIBLE]
term at the--
or near the origin, a
phenomenological choice?
PROFESSOR: If you are
using as a formula
for this the
Lennard-Jones potential,
people phenomenologically
write something
like 1 over r to the
12th power, et cetera.
But I don't have to assume that.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Because I've seen forms of
the Lennard-Jones potential
which is exponentially
decaying at the origin.
So it reaches a finite,
albeit probably high value
at the origin.
Wouldn't that take
care of the issue?
PROFESSOR: If you believe in
that kind of potential, yes.
So what you are
saying is that if I
make this come to
a finite value,
I will be able to find
the temperature that
is sufficiently high
compared to this,
and then things would be fine.
If we had that, then we would
have fusion right here going
on, right?
So clearly, there
is some better truth
to a potential that is really
very, very high compared
to temperatures that
we are looking at.
So we don't have to
worry about that.
Well, we have to worry
about this issue.
OK?
All right.
So you say, well, how about
the following-- let's say
that I am something like
the gas in this room
and I am sufficiently dilute.
I'm going to forget
about these terms.
But since this potential
becomes essentially large,
I can never ignore a
particular term in this series.
And I keep going adding more
and more terms in the series.
If I sort of think
back about the picture
that I was generating before
diagrammatically-- which again,
we will clarify
later on-- this term
corresponds to taking a
pair of points and a V
that connects them.
And this term
corresponds to two V's
going between the
same pair of points.
And you say, well,
there will be terms
that will involve three
V's, four V's, and they
will contribute in the series in
a manner that I can recognize.
So why don't I add all
of those terms together?
And if you like, we can call
the resulting object something
else.
What is that something else?
Well, what I have done
is I have minus beta V.
Well, all of them--
so what is this?
It is the integral d cubed q.
I have minus beta V
plus 1/2 beta V squared.
The next term is
going to be minus 1
over 3 factorial beta V
cubed because it will come
from the third-order
term in the expansion.
And I can go on.
And you say, well,
obviously this whole thing
came from the expansion
of e to the minus beta V
except that I don't have
the 0 order term, 1.
So this quantity that I will
call f of q rather than V of q
is obtained as e to the
minus beta V of q minus 1.
So if I were to, in fact,
add up an infinite number
of terms in the series
rather than having
to integrate V V squared
V cubed, each one of them
is divergence.
I have to integrate this f of q.
So let's see what this f of
q-- or correspondingly, f of r
looks like as a function of r.
So in the range that
I have my hard core
and V is large and positive,
this is going to give me 0.
So the function is
minus 1 down here.
At exactly whatever point it
is that the potential is 0,
then f is also 0.
So basically, I will
come to the same 0.
When the potential is negative,
this will be larger than 1.
My f will be positive.
So presumably, it
will have some kind
of a peak around
where this peak is.
And then at large distances,
it goes back towards 0.
So this is going to go back
towards 1 minus 1, which is 0.
So actually, this
end of the potential
is the same thing as minus beta.
And whereas I couldn't integrate
any one term in this series,
I can certainly integrate
the sum over all positions
and it will give
me a number, which
will depend on
temperature, the properties
of the potential, et cetera.
And it is that number
that will tell me
what the density squared term in
the expression for the pressure
is and what the second
Virial coefficient is.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is this basically
an excluded volume of sorts?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So this part if I
sent it to infinity,
corresponds to an
excluded volume.
So if you want really excluded
volume, this would be minus 1
up to some point.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
But I'm talking
about very general,
so I would say that
excluded volume can
be very easily captured
within this [INAUDIBLE].
All right.
So we want to sort of
follow-up from here.
But since you will
have a problem set,
I will mention one other thing.
That this reorganization of
the series that I made here
is appropriate to the limit
of low densities, where
I would have a nice expansion
in powers of density.
The problem that
you will deal with
has to do with plasmas,
where the interaction
range is very large.
And you already saw
something along those lines
when we had the Vlasov
equation as opposed
to Boltzmann equation.
There was a regime where
you had to reorganize
the series different ways.
In that case, it was
the BBGKY hierarchy
whether you were looking at the
dense limit or a dilute limit.
So this is the analog of where
the Boltzmann equation would
have been inappropriate.
The analog of the
regime where you
are dense and something
like the Vlasov equation
would be appropriate.
So there is some kind
of interaction range,
n d cubed if it is
much larger than 1.
Then it turns out that rather
than looking at diagrams that
have the fewest number of
points-- in this case, 2--
you have to look
at diagrams that
have the largest
number of points.
Because each additional
point will give you
an additional
factor of N over V.
You can see that these
factors of N N minus 1 over 2
came from the number of
points that I had selected.
So if I had to
select three points,
I would have N cubed and the
corresponding V. So the more
points that I have
in my series, I
will have more powers
of the density.
So in that case, it
turns out that rather
than looking at two points
and all lines between them,
you organize things
in terms of what
are called ring
diagrams, which are
things such as this, this, this.
So basically, for a
given number of lines,
the most number of points is
obtained by creating your ring.
And so one of the
problems that you have
is to sort of sum these ring
diagrams and see what happens.
But it seems like what
I'm telling you here
is while we calculated
order of density squared,
but maybe I want to calculate
order of density cubed.
And it makes much more
sense rather than when
faced with potentials
of this form arranging
the series in powers of
the potential to arrange it
in powers of this quantity e
to the minus beta V minus 1.
So let's go through a
route in which I directly
expand everything in
terms of this quantity.
And that's the second
type of expansion
that I will call the
cluster expansion.
So once more, what
we want to calculate
is the partition function.
It depends on temperature,
volume, number
of particles obtained
by integrating over
all degrees of freedom.
The integration over momenta
we saw is very simple.
Ultimately, will give us this
N factorial lambda to the 3N.
This time, I won't pull
out the factor of V
to the N at this point.
And then I have the integration
over all of these q's.
I did not divide by
V because I did not
multiply by V to the N. OK.
And then I have e
to the minus beta U,
but this is my U. U is
the sum of various terms.
So e to the minus beta U
will be a product over all,
let's say-- let's
call this k pairs ij.
e to the minus beta
V of qi minus qj.
So basically, the
only thing that I did
was e to the minus
beta-- this quantity
I wrote as a product
of contributions
from the different pairs.
Now, this quantity I have
it in the line above.
This is also a
relative position.
Clearly, I can
think of this as 1
plus the f that would correspond
to the distance between qi
and qj.
And again, I can either write
it as Vf of qi minus qj,
or simplify of i-- my notation--
and write it as f i j.
So f i j means-- so let
me maybe write it here.
f i j I have defined to
be e to the minus beta
V of qi minus qj minus 1.
So what do I expect?
I saw that the first
correction to something
that was interesting to me
had one power of f in it
that I had to
ultimately integrate.
So maybe what I should do is I
should start organizing things
in terms of how many f's I have.
So an expansion in powers of f.
So what's going to happen here?
I would have 1 over N
factorial lambda to the 3N.
I have a product of all
of the integrations.
And I have all of these
factors of 1 plus f1 2 times 1.
So basically, this is maybe--
it's really a product of 1
plus f1 2, 1 plus f1 3, 1 plus
all of one of these things.
So the thing that has
least number of f's is
when I pick the 1 from
all of these brackets
that are multiplying each other.
The next term is to
pick 1f from one pair
and all the others would be 1.
The next term would be sum
over ij kl f i j f k l,
and then there will be diagrams
that would progressively
have more and more factors of f.
Now, what I will do is to
represent the various terms
that I generate in this
series diagrammatically.
So first of all, I have to
integrate over N points.
So I put points 1 through
N. So I have 1, 2, 3, 4.
It doesn't matter
how I put them-- N.
And then, this 1
would correspond
to just this diagram.
The next thing is I
put a line for f i j.
So let's say that I
picked in this series
the term that was f 2 3.
I will represent that by a
line that goes between 2 and 3.
Later on in the
picture, maybe I will
pick a term that is f 2 3 f 4 5.
So some second-order term
could be something like this.
Maybe later on in
the series, I will
pick a term that is
connecting f3 and f4.
So this would be a third-order
term in the series.
Maybe later on the series, I
have some other pair over here.
So any one of the
huge number of terms
that I have generated
here has one diagram
that is appearing over here.
Now, the next step is, of course
I have to integrate over all
of the q's.
I mean, these diagrams, what
they represent is essentially
some f of q1 minus q3,
some f of whatever.
And I have to integrate
over all of these q's.
So the contribution to
the partition function
that I will get would
be some value associated
with one of these
graphs obtained by doing
the integrations over q.
Now, the thing that
I want you to notice
is that contribution of one
of these graphs or diagrams
is the product of contributions
of its linked clusters.
So here I have one
particular diagram
that is represented here.
Well, let's say 2, 3,
4, 5 are linked together
and separate from
whatever this is.
Let's say this is 7, 9.
So when I do the integrations
over q2, q3, q4, q5,
I don't really rely on
any of the other things.
So my integration
here, we break off
into the integration
that involves
this, the integration that
involves this, as well
as integrations over
all of these points
that are not
connected to anybody.
All of those will simply
give me a factor of v.
So is everybody happy
with this simple statement
that the contribution-- if I
think of these linked clusters
as some collection of points
that are linked together,
the value that I would
get for this diagram
would be the contribution--
product of the contributions
that I would have for this.
So yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you
explain [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So let's pick a
particular thing.
Let's say we do
something like this,
where this is number
7, 245, 6, 5, 4.
This is a particular thing.
So what do I have to do?
There's also a whole
bunch of points-- 1, 2, 3.
What I am instructed to
do is to integrate over
q1, q2, q3, et cetera.
Now, the integral over q1
is just the integral of q1.
So this integral by
itself will give me
V. Any number of points
that are by themselves
will also give me
V. So the first term
that becomes
nontrivial is when I
have to do the integration over
q4, q5, q6 of f 4 5, f 5 6,
f 6 4.
I don't know what
this is, but there
is something that
will come from here.
Then, later on I have
to integrate over 7
and something else.
So then I have the integral
over q7, q-- let's call this 8.
f of 7 8.
So this is something else.
So the overall value of this
term in the perturbation theory
is the product of contributions
from a huge number of one
clusters.
Here, I have a two cluster.
Here, I have a three cluster.
Maybe I will have more things.
Also, notice that if I have
more of these two clusters,
the result for them would
be exactly the same.
So if I have lots of these
pairs, the same way that I
had lots of single
points-- and it became V
to the number of
single points-- it
will become whatever that
y is to the number of pair
points, x, whatever that is,
to the number of triplets
that I have in triangles.
So this is how this
object is built up.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How are we
deciding how many triplets
and how many pairs
we actually have?
PROFESSOR: At this point,
I haven't told you.
So there is a multiplicity
that we have to calculate.
Yes.
So at this point, all
I'm saying is given
this, the answer is the
product of contribution.
There is a multiplicity
factor-- you're right.
We have to calculate that.
OK?
Anything else?
All right.
So I mean, think of
this as taking a number
and writing it as the
product of its prime factors,
factorizing into primes.
So you sort of immediately know
that somehow prime factors,
the prime numbers,
are more important.
Because everything else you
can write as prime numbers.
So clearly, what is
also buried in heart
of calculating this partition
function is these clusters.
So let me define the analog
of prime numbers as follows.
I define bl to be the
sum over contributions
of all linked
clusters of l-points.
So let's go term by term.
b1 corresponds essentially
to the one point
by itself in the diagram
that I was drawing down here.
And corresponds to
integrating over
the coordinate that
goes all over the space.
And hence, the volume is the
same thing as the volume V.
b2 is a cluster of two points.
So it is this.
And so it is the
integral over q1 and q2,
which are two endpoints of
this, of f of q1 minus q2.
And this we have seen
already many times.
It's the same thing as volume,
the integral over q f of q.
It is the thing that was
related to our second Virial
coefficient.
Now, this is very
important for b3.
I note that I
underlined here "all."
And this is for
later convenience.
It seems that I'm essentially
pushing complexity
from one place to another.
So there are a
number of diagrams
that have three things
linked together.
This is one of them.
Let's say, think of 1, 2,
3 connected to each other.
But then, I have diagrams.
At this stage, I
don't really care
that this is one
particle irreducible.
Here, I have no constraints on
one particle irreducibility.
And in fact, this comes
in three varieties
because the bond that is
missing can be one of three.
So once I pick the triplets
of three points, sum
over all clusters that involve
these three points is this,
in particular with this
one, appearing three times.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do we still
count all the diagrams
when particles are identical?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Because here, at
this stage, there
is an N factorial out here.
All I'm really doing
is transcribing
a mathematical formula.
The mathematical
formula says you
have to do a bunch
of integrations.
And I am just
following translating
that mathematical
formula to diagrams.
At this stage, we forget.
This has nothing to do with
this N factorial or identity.
It's just a transcription
of the mathematics
So at this stage, don't try
to correct my conceptual parts
but try to make sure that my
mathematical steps are correct.
OK?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I didn't
understand what
that missing links represents.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So at the end of this story,
what I want to write down
is that the value of some
particular term in this series
is related to product
of contributions.
I described to you how
productive contributions
comes along.
And each contribution
is a bunch of points
that are connected together.
So what I want to do, in order
to make my algebra easier
later on, is to say
that-- let's say
these three points
are part of a cluster.
They are connected
together somehow.
So they will be
giving me some factor.
Now, they are connected, if
they are connected like this,
like this, like this, like that.
So basically, any
one of these is
a way of connecting these
three points so that they
will make a
contribution together.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So the one
with all three bonds
comes with a
different [INAUDIBLE]
in the series than the ones
with only two bonds, right?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Now, there is
reason, ultimately,
why I want to group
all of them together.
Because there was a
question before about
multiplicity factors.
I can write down a closed
form, nice expression
for the multiplicity factor
if I group them together.
Otherwise, I have to also worry
that there are three of these
and there is one
of them, et cetera.
There is an additional
layer of multiplicity.
And I want to separate those
two layers of multiplicity.
So here, the thing that I have
is I have these endpoints.
I want to say that the
eventual result for endpoints
comes from clusters that
involves 1's, clusters that
involve pairs, and cluster
that involve triplets.
Now, I realize suddenly that if
I made the multiplicity count
here, then for this triplet,
I could have put all of them
together like this or like that.
And the next order
of business when
I am thinking
about four objects,
I can connect them together
into a cluster in multiple ways.
And there is a separate
way of calculating
the relative
multiplicity of what
comes outside and the
multiplicity of this quartic
with respect to entirety.
So you have to think
about this a little bit.
So I'll proceed with this.
So this mathematically would
be the integral q1, q2, q3, f
1 2, f 2 3, f 3 1 plus, say,
f 1 2, f 2 3, plus f 1 3 f 3 2
plus f 2 3, f 3 1,
something like this.
Well, 1, 2.
2 is repeated.
3 is repeated.
I should repeat 1.
OK.
Of course, the last
three are the same thing,
but this is the
expression for this.
Now, before would be a
huge complex of things.
It would have a diagram
that is of this form.
It would have a number of
diagrams that are of this form.
It would have diagrams that
are of this form, diagrams
that are like
this, and so forth.
Basically, even
within the choice
of things that
have four clusters,
there is a huge
number when you go
to further and
further [? down. ?]
OK, so maybe this statement
will now clarify things.
So what I have is that
the partition function
is 1 over N factorial
lambda to the 3N.
And then it is all
of the terms that
are obtained by
summing this series.
And so I have to look
at all possible ways
that I can break N-points
into these clusters.
Suppose I created a situation
where I have clusters of size l
and then I have nl of them.
So I saw that the contribution
that I would get from the 1
clusters was
essentially the product
of the number of 1 clusters.
It was V to the
number of points that
are not connected together.
So I have to take b1, raise
it to the power of N1,
which is the number
of 1 cluster.
Then, I have to do the same
thing for b2, b3, et cetera.
And then I have to
make sure that I
have looked at all
ways of partitioning
N the numbers into
these clusters.
So I have a sum over nl
l has to add up to n.
And I have to sum
over all nl's that are
consistent with this constraint.
But then there is this
issue of the multiplicity.
Given that I chose some
articular set of these,
if I were to
reorganize the numbers,
I would get the
same contribution.
So let's say we pick
this diagram that
has precisely a
contribution that
is V, which is b1 to the
number of these one points.
This to the number
of b2 to the power
of the number of
these, this, et cetera.
But then I can take these
labels-- 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6-- that I assigned to these
things and permute them.
If I permute them, I will get
exactly the same contribution.
So there is a large
number of diagrams
that have exactly this
same contribution because
of this permutation.
There was a question back there.
AUDIENCE: You've
already answered it.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Actually, this is an
interesting thing--
I don't know how many
of you recognize this.
So essentially, I have
to take a huge number, N,
and break it into a number
of 1 clusters, 2 clusters, et
cetera.
The number of ways
of doing that is
called a partition
of an integer.
And last century,
the [INAUDIBLE]
calculated what that number is.
So there is a [INAUDIBLE]
theorem associated with that.
And actually,
later in the course
I will give you a
problem to calculate
the asymptotic version
of the [INAUDIBLE].
But this is different story.
So given that you had made
one of these partitions
of this integer, what is
this degeneracy factor?
So let me tell you what
this degeneracy factor is.
So given this
choice of nl's, you
say-- well, the first
thing is what I told you.
For a particular
graph, the value
is independent of how these
numbers were assigned.
So I will permute those
numbers in all possible ways
and I will get the same thing.
So that will give
me N factorial.
It's the number of permutations.
But then, I have over-counted
things because within,
let's say, a 2 cluster--
if I count 7, 8, 8,
7 they are the same thing.
And by multiplying
by this N factorial,
I have over-counted that.
So I have to divide by 2 for
every one of my 2 clusters.
So I have to divide by
2 to the power of N2.
For the 3 clusters, I have
the permutation of everything
that is inside.
So it is 3 factor here.
So what I have here
is I have to divide
by the over-counting, which
is l factorial-- labels
within a cluster-- to
the number of clusters
that I have that
are subject to this.
There is another thing that this
pair is 100, 101 and this pair
is 7, 8.
Exchanging that pair of numbers
with that pair of numbers
is also part of the symmetries
that I have now over-counted.
So that has to be
taken into account
because the number of
these 2 clusters here is 2.
Here is actually 3.
I have to divide by 3 factorial.
In general, I have to
divide by nl factorial.
OK.
Again, this is one
of those things
that the best advice that I
can give you is to draw five
or six points so
your n is small.
And draw some diagrams.
And convince yourself
that what I told you
here rapidly is correct.
And it is correct.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you just clarify
which is in the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So the N factorial is outside.
And then-- so maybe
write it better.
For each l, I have to
multiply nl factorial and l
factorial to the power of nl.
So this is my partition function
in terms of these clusters.
Even with all of
these definitions
that I have up there, maybe
not so obvious an answer.
And one of the reason it is
kind of an obscure answer
is because here I have
to do a constrained sum.
That is, I have all
of these variables.
Let's call them n1,
n2, n3, et cetera.
Each one of them can
go from 0, 1, 2, 3.
But they are all
linked to each other
because their sum is kind of
restricted by some total value
l, by this constraint.
And constrained
sums are hard to do.
But in statistical
physics, we know
how to gets rid of
constrained sums.
The way that we do
that is we essentially
allow this N to go all the way.
So if I say, let's make--
it's very hard for me
to do this n1 from
0 to something,
n2 from 0 to something with
all of this constrained.
My life would be very easier
if I could independently
have n1 go take any
value, n2 take any value,
n3 take any value.
But if I do that essentially
for each choice of n1, n2, n3,
I have shifted the
value of big N.
But there is an
ensemble that I know
which has possibly
any value of N,
and that's the grand canonical.
So rather than looking at
the partition function,
I say I will look at the
grand partition function
Q that is obtained
by summing over
all N. Can take any
value from 0 to infinity.
I have e to the beta mu N times
the partition function that
is for N particles.
So that's the definition of how
you would go from the canonical
where you have fixed
N to grand canonical
where you have fixed the
chemical potential mu.
So let's apply this
sum over there.
I have a sum over N, but
I said that if I allowed
the nl's to vary
independently, it
is equivalent to varying
that N, recognizing
that this n is sum over l l nl.
That's the constraint.
So that's just the first term.
I have rewritten this sum that
was constrained and this sum
over the total number as
independent sums over the nl's.
Got rid of the constraint.
Now, I write W. Oh, OK.
The partition function.
Now, write the
partition function.
I have 1 over N factorial.
I have lambda cubed
raised to this power.
So actually, let me put
this in this fashion.
So both e to the
beta mu over lambda
cubed that is raised
to that power.
OK, so that's that part.
The sum I have gotten rid of.
I notice that my W
has an N factorial.
So this is the N factorial
that came from here.
But then there is an N factorial
that is up here from the W.
So the two of them will cancel
each other, N factorial.
And then I have a product
over all clusters.
Part of it is this bl
to the power of nl,
and then I have the contribution
that is nl factorial l
factorial to the power of nl.
So this part cancels.
For each l, I can
now independently
sum over the values of nl can
be anything, 0 to infinity.
And what do I have?
I have bl to the power of nl.
I have division by nl factorial.
I have l factorial
to the power of nl.
And then I have e to the beta
mu over lambda cubed raised
to the power of l nl.
I recognize that each one
of these terms in the sum
is 1 over nl factorial something
raised to the power of nl,
which is the definition
of the exponential.
So my q is a product
over all l's.
Once I exponentiate, I
have e to the beta mu
over lambda cubed raised
to the power of l.
And then I have bl
divided by l factorial.
Or, log of Q, which is the
quantity that I'm interested,
is obtained by summing
over all clusters 1
to infinity e to the beta
mu over lambda cubed raised
to the power of l bl
divided by l factorial.
So what does this
tell us, which is
kind of nice and
fundamentally important?
You see, we started at
the beginning over here
with a huge number of graphs.
These graphs could be organizing
all kinds of clusters.
And they would give us
either the partition function
or summing over N, the
grand partition function.
But when we take the log, I get
only single connect objects.
And this is something
that you had already
seen as the connection
that we have
between moments and Cumulants.
So the way that we
got Cumulants was
to look at the
expansion of the log.
So the function itself was
the generator of all moments
and we took the log.
And graphically,
we presented that
as getting the moments
by putting together
all kinds of clusters of points
that corresponded to Cumulants.
And this is again,
a representation
of the same thing.
That is, in the log
you have essentially
individual contributions.
Once you exponentiated, you
get multiple contributions.
Now, the other thing is, that
if I am thinking about the gas,
then log of Q is e
to the minus beta g.
And g is E minus TS minus
mu N. Bur for a gas that
has extensive properties,
E is TS mu N minus PV.
So this is the same
thing as beta PV.
So this quantity that
we have calculated here
is, in fact, related
to the pressure
directly through this formula.
And the important part or
the important observation
is that it says that it should
be proportional to volume.
You can see that
each one of my b's
that I calculated here will
have one free integral.
If you like, its center of mass.
You can go over
the entire volume.
So all of my b's are indeed
proportionality to volume.
And you can see what
disaster it would
have been if there was a term
here that was not just a linked
cluster but product of
two linked clusters.
Then I would have something
that would go like V squared.
It's not allowed.
So essentially, this linked
cluster nature is also
related to extensivity
in this sense.
So in some sense, what I have
established here-- again,
related to that-- is that
clearly all of my bl's
are proportional to volume.
And I can define
something that I
will call bl bar, which is
divide the thing by the volume.
And then what we
have established
is that the pressure of this
interacting gas as an expansion
beta p, which takes this
nice, simple form, sum over l
e to the beta mu divided
by lambda cubed bl
bar-- the intensive part of the
contribution of these cluster--
divided by l factorial.
This, of course, runs
from 1 to [INAUDIBLE].
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
is raised to the l?
PROFESSOR: Who's
asking the question?
AUDIENCE: The term in the
parentheses is raised to the l?
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
Thank you very much.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
But they don't, actually.
Could that be true, for
example [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So the triangle, I have it here.
Integral d q1, d q2, d
Q3, f 1 2, f 2 3, f 3.
Let's write it explicitly.
It is f of q1 minus q2, f of
q2 minus q3, f of q3 minus q1.
I call this vector x.
I call that vector y.
This vector is x plus y.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Does the
contribution from [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So you say that I have here
an expansion for the pressure.
I had given you previously
an expansion for pressure
that I said is sensible, which
is this Virial expansion, which
is powers of density.
This is not an expansion
in powers of density.
So whether or not the
terms in this expansion
becomes smaller or
larger will depend
on density in some indirect way.
So my next task, which
I will do next lecture,
is within this ensemble
I have told you
what the chemical potential is.
Once I know what the
chemical potential is,
I can calculate the
number of particles
as d log Q by d beta mu.
And hence, I can calculate
what the density is.
And so the answer for this will
also be a series in powers of e
to the beta mu.
And what then I will do is
I will combine these two
series to get an expansion for
pressure in powers of density,
and then identify the
convergence of this series
and all of that
via that procedure.